Guantanamo has been built on how to
destroy a human being totally how to do
to damage him mentally physically
spiritually this is a story of 779
Muslim men and boys who were held at the
Guantanamo Bay detention center and of
them the 40 who still remained there to
this day
9/11 was difficult for all of us for all
Americans but I think what the
intervening 17 years now have shown is
that abandoning our long-standing legal
systems and our values are not rewarding
for us they don't strengthen national
security in the 17 years since hundreds
of non citizen Muslim men and boys were
sold into u.s. imprisonment kept without
charge and tortured there has yet to be
any accountability and any real justice
we the United States have done such a
good job of convincing our population
and the entire world that these men are
terrorists that it is impossible for men
to escape Guantanamo when they're
released and that's their biggest
complaint is that everybody thinks
they're a terrorist I try so hard to act
to be normal but it is hard
[Music]
in order to understand how and why there
are still men held without charge in
Guantanamo we have to start at the
beginning of the long history the United
States has in Guantanamo Bay in 1898
following the spanish-american war
the United States took control of
several territories previously
controlled by Spain including 45 square
miles of Fontana mo Bay Cuba
and even after Cuban independence the
u.s. maintained control through leasing
the land and it became a naval base in
1991 during a coup d'etat in Haiti
refugees set out on makeshift rafts and
boats to claim asylum in Florida but the
US had other plans for the Haitians
President George HW Bush found that he
couldn't send them back home so the
Coast Guard started rerouting the
refugees to the Guantanamo Bay Naval
Base in less than a year nearly 37,000
people were living in tent cities ringed
with barbed wire back in the US a
district court judge condemned the
conditions and ordered the camp closed a
decision that was later reversed Shaina
Cuddy doll of the Center for
Constitutional Rights was at Yale Law
School at the time and was part of a
group of professors and students that
worked on the Haitian Guantanamo case so
you have people who are not American
citizens these Haitian refugees landing
in a place that technically is Cuban but
in every other practical respect belongs
to the United States of America then the
question is do they have you know full
of siloam rights under United States law
and maybe even a preliminary question do
they have the right to even set foot in
American federal courts and make
arguments about what rights they do have
and it's that line of questioning and
that legal framework that forms the
basis of how the US government would
treat detainees arrested during the
so-called war on terror our war on
terror begins with al Qaeda but it does
not end there
on October 7th 2001 the United States
invaded Afghanistan in search of Osama
bin Laden and other al Qaeda operatives
believed to be behind the 9/11 attacks
and believed to be under the protection
of the Taliban and there was a big push
to capture anyone
alleged to be an al Qaeda operative as
Alka Pradhan a lawyer on the Guantanamo
Military Commissions who represents
several current and former
explains what we actually did is we
dropped fliers over the tribal areas and
the border areas between Pakistan and
Afghanistan saying if you give us
members of al-qaeda we will pay you
anywhere from I think it was up to five
thousand dollars President Musharraf
Pakistan is on the record as gloating
about how much money the Pakistani
government made from turning over people
to the United States whom they just
labeled as terrorists pretty much
anybody who was an Arab in Afghanistan
after 9/11 was worth twenty years salary
to hungry villagers to corrupt warlords
to corrupt Pakistani policemen Manning
the border and so with the bounties
ranging from three thousand dollars to
twenty five thousand dollars the United
States begins piling up these men really
quickly who are held without charge and
without proof
many were picked up for just being at
the wrong place at the wrong time or
even wearing the wrong kind of watch one
of our council likes to say that being
foreign in Afghanistan after 9/11 was
like driving while black one example of
this was Purdon's client Ahmad Hassan a
Yemeni student in Pakistan who when he
was sold was asked by US military
officials if he knew al-qaeda to which
he responded yes and they said okay all
right well you're coming with us and he
was sent to one of the camps or he was
just brutally tortured he was stripped
naked he was beaten he was subjected to
freezing temperatures and during this
time he was interrogated again and he
was asked do you know al-qaeda and he at
this point realized that perhaps there
was some mix-up and it turns out that
the al-qaeda Hassan knew was a small
village in Yemen Husson told that he
would be let go would remain in
Guantanamo until 2015
thirteen years after he was sold to the
US military now with all these men who
had been rounded up they needed to be
kept somewhere having the detainees on
US soil was quickly discarded as an
option since that would give them
certain rights and privileges the
thought process at that time that
Rumsfeld and and others at the
Department of Defense are going through
is where can we hold them where we don't
have to apply US law
where we don't have to apply the
Constitution but they are still going to
be under our complete control
that brings us to Guantanamo Bay Naval
Base the first detainees arrived there
from Afghanistan and Pakistan in January
of 2002 they get off the airplane and we
have no idea who they are where they're
from what their alleged to have done
anything like that we in some cases
don't even have names for them despite
not knowing much about who they had
captured the US government had to build
a case against each individual they
don't approach it as you're innocent
until you're proven guilty they approach
it as these men are all enemies of the
United States and so they start
interrogating them once they were
brought to Guantanamo were you chained
in what we called stress positions which
are essentially you know chained from
their wrists from the ceiling or had
their wrists and their ankles chained
together or had dog collars placed
around their necks and chained to the
walls some of them had those dog collars
actually attached to leashes and were
then dragged around floors while being
quote interrogated for shocker armor a
British resident who spent 14 years in
Guantanamo without charge there was
something worse than the physical
torture he endured once you get beaten
up once you get hiring don't you get all
these whatever they call it hug ties and
all these things pain physical pain then
it goes away you know but when they try
to play with you mentally and
psychologically all kind of manipulation
you you feel like every time they find
something new as word started to leak
about conditions in Guantanamo groups
like the Center for Constitutional
Rights started petitioned to have the
detainees cases heard in federal courts
Tecate dolls surprise they won the
landmark case
Rasual versus Bush we win the Supreme
Court case in late June of 2004 and
suddenly the government realizes that
it's going to have to go in and defend
its detention of each one of these
individuals in federal court so
immediately they started having to you
know pulled together files on people
those files the government was putting
together were the biographies that would
come to define these men and they were
based on evidence obtained from the
so-called enhanced interrogation
techniques which by the way is
considered coerced evidence and is
inadmissible under international law and
even US law the biographies were also
based on information gathered by former
detainees turned informants we know now
from reporting in The Washington Post
that they were individual detainees who
got their own separate housing
electronic sound systems and little TVs
to watch movies on in exchange for
informing on their fellow detainees not
only is this false evidence probably the
most important evidence that the United
States has according to Pradhan it's
also on the public record the
biographies were leaked by WikiLeaks as
part of the Guantanamo files in 2011 to
this day if you google you know Eman
Hassan or Abu LD up or any of my former
clients the first thing I think that
comes up are these biographies many of
the facts in which we proved to be false
they all sound very very similar it
seems like every detainee at Guantanamo
was asana bin Laden's brother-in-law and
every detainee at Guantanamo fought with
with bin Laden at Tora Bora and these
false biographies continue to haunt them
today even after they've been released
in total the United States would come to
imprison 779 detainees with 21 being
children under the age of 18 when they
were caught the youngest believed to be
13 years old of those 779 to this day
732 have been released many of them many
years after they were first detained and
without a single charge having been
brought against them the Bush
administration oversaw the release of
five hundred and thirty-two detainees
either back to their home countries or
to another country willing to accept
them and when Barack Obama was
campaigning for the presidency in 2008
one of his major campaign promises was
to shut down Guantanamo we did see when
he came into office within the first day
and we have that executive order that
comes down to close Guantanamo Bay while
honorable will be closed no later than
one year from now things go south very
very quickly
despite the Democrats having control of
the House and Senate the Obama
administration didn't follow through on
the promise of shutting down Guantanamo
and didn't even try to clear the names
of all those wrongfully detained and
tortured that's what I
to be just absolutely unforgivable is
that we know all of this false
information is there but President Obama
will not stand up and say hey we got it
wrong these were all mistakes made and
solely because we were not willing to
face up to our own mistakes as a country
we continue to perpetrate torture at
Guantanamo and that lack of reeducation
and accountability has had an impact on
the men who were released the same guard
who will attack you and fight you and
choke you and the same guard in another
occasion will Britain that he's your
friend you don't know how to feel you
don't know the difference between hate
and love you don't know really you don't
know your feeling is all jumbled
together they can't get jobs they can't
get education people won't befriend them
having detained these men for years upon
years taken decades of their lives
taking them away from their families
mentally you debilitated them really and
then release them to places where they
don't know how to get by it's a human
rights and humanitarian crisis of
enormous enormous order today 40 men
remain in Guantanamo
with only seven having been charged and
even their charges depend on weak
information and questionable links for
further who represents detainee Omar al
balochi the nephew of alleged 9/11
mastermind Khalid Sheikh Mohammed the
question of injustice faced by detainees
past and present is a question of
injustice that impacts American citizens
as well Americans should care about it
again because it is so much more than
just those 40 men Guantanamo is the root
of all of the national security debates
that we have now the utter disregard for
people of color because they are people
of color that colors our debates on
immigration on the refugee crisis on
prison reform
here in the United States so Montano
really is sort of and continues to be
the crucible where all of these
violations really were born and they
continue to spin out from Guantanamo
it's sort of it's the crucible the
epicenter of all of that hey guys thanks
for watching
wonton mo is a really tough subject to
tackle and we only scratch the surface
in our story let us know in the comments
what you think and don't forget to Like
share and follow and we'll see you next
week